so today i'm going to talk about the 20
signs that you have
too much stress now the first thing i
want to mention is that in practice
i had a machine that measured
internally what's going on with the
autonomic nervous system specifically
the flight or fight mechanism which is
everything to do with stress and this
machine was called heart rate
variability it's a great test and you
could measure what's going on internally
with the flight or flight mechanism and
also the recovery
mechanism which is called the
parasympathetic nervous system
now some people would come in
really really stressed out
and it didn't look like they were
massively stressed out on the graph
but they were definitely in the stress
mode yet other people would come in
showing massive
flutter fight stress
yet they were calm able to cope with
stress so i just want to point out one
thing
you have your body and then you have you
you may have been endowed with a
incredible ability to tolerate stress
and you can cope with stress very well
so regardless of what's happening in
your body
you might not feel stressed too much yet
other people just have a poor ability to
handle stress so that's a little bit of
a variable that makes things a little
complex because it's not just always
about what's happening to your adrenal
glands so if you go get a saliva test
and it says that you're in stress but
you don't feel stress it just means you
yourself are able to handle stress very
well so i don't want to invalidate that
but i do want to mention that i'm going
to give you a lot of things to help
cope with stress better and also
strengthen your body's ability to cope
with stress on that note let's start
with the brain and how stress affects
the brain and i'm talking primarily
about cortisol
now our bodies were not designed yet to
handle
chronic stress
acute stress yes but not chronic stress
the stress that an average person
endures right now um is just way way
over the top especially because it's
chronic stress okay people are basically
living in a stress bucket 24 7. so the
way that it affects the brain
is that
it puts you in
problem
solving mode 24 7. you just can't not
solve problems in fact you're fixated on
certain problems and it's very hard to
unfixate on those problems so you might
have a great day and you come home and
you're just constantly thinking of this
one problem over and over and over
despite maybe 98 of the things went
right in your life
your attention goes to that thing that
went wrong so one of the things with the
adrenals and
cortisol is that you can't do anything
else but
solve problems 24 7. the other aspect
about this is the tolerance to stress
your ability to cope with stress as your
stress starts building and your adrenal
system gets weaker uh you just don't
tolerate stress anymore and this can be
um in complete overwhelm where you just
break down and start crying or it could
be in a severe irritability or anger
when you experience
things that are too much stress and so
if you look at the adrenal glands as a
survival gland anything that is opposite
to that is going to be a stress like
anything that is illogical like if you
have people around you that are logical
incompetent insane boy that just really
uh just jacks up your adrenals but if
you're an environment that's sane
logical
everyone's competent everyone's
supportive
you'll do much better so one really
common thing is like slow drivers
i guess that would be considered
incompetent drivers if they're driving
like two miles an hour and they're right
ahead of you boy that just will just
raise your blood pressure so i guess the
best term would be
how much patience you have right or
don't have that's a real good index of
your adrenal function and your ability
to cope with stress and another point
about the adrenals is that it puts you
in a state of um flight or fight where
you're thinking really really fast so
sometimes when you're talking to someone
that's talking very slow that can bug
you you're already done with the
conversation you already know what
they're going to say and sometimes you
might complete their senses which can
create some problems and also your
ability to
focus on maybe one thing might be very
difficult with adrenal issues so you
might be a little bit dispersed
thinking about this doing that
multitasking is what i'm talking about
the problem is you don't really feel
productive because
you have a lot of incomplete things and
projects that are going on which then
adds more stress all right the next
point is you're not a morning person
i used to be not a morning person in
fact it took me until like 11 o'clock in
the morning before i could wake up now i
am definitely a morning person that's
the best time of the day i'm most
creative i'm most awake that's when i'm
doing videos like right now but if
there's an adrenal issue and you have a
lot of stress
the morning is going to be difficult
you're going to have a hard time getting
out of bed you're going to even need
this thing called
coffee and in large amounts you know
what's interesting about caffeine
is it doesn't necessarily boost your
energy per se
it gets rid of the things that are
making you tired
so it's getting rid of this these
factors that help you sleep
so
if you minus those you're just going to
feel very very awake but in the long run
when you drink too much coffee caffeine
you're going to be burning those
adrenals out like myself
in fact i was drinking
pots of coffee in college um
not just any coffee like cuban coffee so
i burnt my adrenals out early on all
right next one is your your sleep cycles
are going to be not very good you're
going to be a poor sleeper
a real um good indicator of
a spike in cortisol is at two o'clock or
2 30 in the middle of night you're very
awake you're more awake than than you
are during the day during the day you
have brain fog but you're very very
awake at two o'clock that was me for
many many years now i think um
the best way to test your adrenals is
with an hiv heart rate variability a
test
which you just have to find someone to
do that test because when you do a blood
test your adrenals have to be literally
like 90
dysfunctional before it even shows up
but you can also do a 24 hour saliva
test it's kind of a pain in the butt
because you have to
get up to the night you have to
spit into these little tubes and then
send them off for a test but that's also
a good way to measure cortisol
the heart rate variability test measures
the flight or fight mechanism more than
it does cortisol but just another way to
to measure your adrenals and they have a
lot of different new apps coming out on
your cell phone i think attachments that
you can measure heart rate variability
to give you some indication what's going
on with your
your stress level but unfortunately the
one that i used um
years ago they don't sell anymore that
was a real easy test to measure your
adrenals but sleep is going to suck if
you have too much stress and then not
enough sleep then makes you more
stressed and also affects your blood
sugars next thing is blood sugars
themselves the adrenal hormone called
cortisol is called a glucocorticoid it's
a hormone that releases blood sugar from
your muscles and your liver
as well as
turning
non-carbohydrate things like
protein and fat into sugar so when you
go through stress you're basically like
eating candy bars without eating candy
bars so
that can elevate the blood sugars and
you can even become a diabetic
by having high levels of cortisol or
even taking cortisol in the form of
prednisone which i've
seen several people turn into diabetics
just from that so with the high blood
glucose then you have high cholesterol
then you have more fat which i'm going
to get to in a second and you also get a
fatty liver all right next point is
you're going to get more visceral fat
that's fat in your belly okay you're
gonna have belly fat a sagging belly
that is high levels of cortisol but it's
really what cortisol is doing to your
insulin levels because it's raising your
blood sugar and then following from that
you have this spike of insulin so we
have a combination of high cortisol and
high insulin and you get this belly fat
at the same time your body is
dissolving or eating up it's called a
catabolic effect on your muscles so your
body is robbing your muscles from your
legs okay your thighs
and the glutamas maximus muscle so
chronic stress puts you in this
this body shape of a sagging belly
with stick legs and
no butt all right the next point about
excess stress would be heavy legs when
you're going up a hill or incline or
stairs
and you're out of breath easily so
that's an indication that
your body can't cope with stress because
you're going up an incline okay or if
you stand up from a seated position or
lying down you get really dizzy really
fast that's another indication that your
body can't cope with stress
there's a really good
test is called a raglans test if you
check your blood pressure
while you're lying down and then when
you're standing
normally your blood pressure should go
up
by about six points
if it goes up by 20 points or it goes
down it kind of gives you an idea of
what's happening to the adrenals whether
your body is overreacting to stress or
under-reacting and can't cope i mean
some people get up too fast and they
actually
faint so that's a severe adrenal problem
all right the next point is
about inflammation cortisol is a natural
anti-inflammatory so when you have high
levels of stress in cortisol the
receptor for cortisol starts to become
resistant
very similar to insulin resistance so it
doesn't work anymore so despite having
high cortisol you don't get the effects
of cortisol so we have a lack of
anti-inflammatories so you get
inflammation so you have arthritis
bursitis tendinitis you have pain
so this is why a common
treatment for inflammation and pain is
prednisone which is a synthetic version
of cortisol
not good though i had over probably 15
rounds of
heavy steroids from poison ivy
in my 20s and 30s and that's really what
pushed me over the edge
because it stopped working so i
cannot have any more steroids all right
the next thing about excessive stress
and adrenal overdrive is a loss of
electrolytes specifically potassium you
lose potassium with stress
so that shows up in elevated blood
pressure it shows up in heart
arrhythmias it shows up in
you can't relax because potassium is a
physiological relaxer helps calm you
down so without potassium everything
kind of goes up with heart rate and a
lot of things and then also you get leg
cramps
and then you have your ratios of sodium
going up and your potassium going down
and that's where you get edema swelling
in the legs this is why it's really good
for an adrenal case or someone going
through a lot of stress to consume
high amounts of potassium
try to get it from the salads large
salads or a good electrolyte but
potassium it definitely affects many
different things including energy all
right next thing is salt cravings why
because the adrenals
need salt to help them function so many
times like after a stressful day you may
even crave salt and then consume salt
and sometimes sugar
because the way that what's happening to
the adrenals and you may just feel
i can breathe better i feel better i
have more energy from that salt um if
you're deficient in salt you'll feel
weaker so the more stress you experience
the more salt you need but don't forget
to add the potassium to that because we
need at least twice as much potassium as
sodium all right the next point
susceptibility to getting sick or having
an infection
the adrenal gland hormone specifically
cortisol is an immune suppressive
hormone so it suppresses the immune
system that's why they give it to people
with
overactive immune systems allergies
autoimmune diseases where there's a lot
of inflammation uh they give you
prednisone which is a type of cortisol
and what that's doing it's suppressing
your immune system it's turning it off
it's turning off this over reaction same
thing with the cytokine storm
they give people prednisone to turn off
that overreaction of your immune system
well when you go through a lot of stress
or a shock to the system like a sudden
loss of a loved one for example
a lot of things can happen to your
immune system it just basically shuts
off and you can develop an autoimmune
disease in fact
when i was in practice i asked people
that had autoimmune diseases when did it
start
i'm not kidding like in like probably 98
of the time maybe 99 of the time it was
after a loss of a loved one or a major
divorce so that adrenal stress can shut
down the
immune system to the point where all
sorts of things can happen like viral
infections things going haywire all
right next point is autoimmune i just
mentioned that autoimmune
diseases are connected to stress and
also
gut permeability issues okay because
that's your barrier to
your immune system so when you have a
gut issue um you can have certain things
invade and cross through the barrier and
start creating these immune reactions on
top of stress
it's just a deadly combination
all right acne
why because
part of the adrenal hormones are
androgens so if you're pumping out too
many androgens you can get an enlarged
sebaceous gland in excess oil and have
acne and not to mention
what cortisol does to
insulin it raises insulin okay and
too much insulin will then make more
androgens especially in females and
that's called polycystic ovarian
syndrome so
you can
develop that from too many carbs or too
much stress
next point i want to talk about is
asthma the medication for asthma is
bronchocorticoid steroid inhalers okay
again cortisol because cortisol is a
vasodilator it helps you breathe it
helps open up the coronary artery as
well as well as the bronchial tubes
asthma is
kind of just a weakness within the
adrenal glands
you know one really cool thing about
vitamin d
vitamin d is kind of a natural
uh form of cortisol without the side
effects it's really a hormone it acts
very similar to cortisol so this is why
if you have asthma or any of these
symptoms you should be taking more
vitamin d because it can definitely help
especially with asthma okay next thing
is allergies i've kind of mentioned that
with the immune system if you have a lot
of allergies it could be a weakness
within the adrenal system and allergies
tend to get worse under stress and so
another indication you have to mistress
is allergies and i already talked about
asthma but i do want to mention one
point about that i mean think about what
happens with asthma especially when
you're with your breathing your
breathing is not calm you're constantly
trying to get air
and i did a video on this i'm going to
put it down below if you haven't seen
this you should watch it because
when you try to get too much oxygen
um you then have an imbalance with co2
and i'm not going to get into it in this
video but the point is that breathing
too much
will stop the absorption of oxygen in
your lungs
and this is why um people that are in
panic attacks should be breathing in a
bag to increase their co2 not the oxygen
so then they can then breathe better but
try to think about what happens when you
um blow up a balloon or hyperventilate
you literally pass out so
watch that video if you haven't seen it
on you know it's on panic attacks and
also asthma all right sinus is
definitely adrenal issues because
cortisol resistance
affects the
sinus passages and they basically swell
up that's why sleep apnea and sinus
issues are related to high levels of
cortisol which then develops cortisol
resistance
which is too much cortisol
chronically all right i already
mentioned sleep apnea osteoporosis
after menopause
um what happens during menopause is the
adrenal glands
now have to back up the ovaries that are
going in retirement if there's
weaknesses within the adrenal system
going into menopause
what happens is it causes a
a problem with
a spike in cortisol and that spike
can start to affect not just hot flashes
but
osteopenia and osteoporosis
because cortisol isn't is a catabolic
hormone it breaks down
protein and a part of
bone is protein so we're basically
thinning the bones i remembered one
dentist that came in to see me
right during menopause now all day long
she's like hovering over people but she
found right when she went through
menopause her entire spine going up into
her neck started to collapse
and she just
she lost height in her spine her body
shrank and she's just like hunchback
right now so
that was that spike in cortisol it's
very destructive
and so that's why it's so important to
strengthen your adrenals before you go
through menopause all right another one
is acid reflux
and gastritis
when you go through stress it can
elevate the amount of acid in your
stomach and also one little side note
which is kind of interesting
you lose
h plus the hydrogen ion
if you know anything about chemistry
it's well it affects the ph but you lose
that with um
with the high levels of cortisol
and so when you go through more stress
you lose the h plus which really is your
acids so then you're not going to have
enough acid and then the body is going
to overcompensate by producing more acid
and also you're not going to be able to
close the valve on the top of the
stomach and that leads to gerd and the
solution is to add more acid like
betaine hydrochloride
to the stomach not to add in antacid
because that is going to make things
worse all right and the last thing is
gallstones cortisol can create a
deficiency of bile and it's a lack of
bile and an excess amount of cholesterol
that can then develop into stones all
right so those are all the indications
that you're going through too much
stress so now what can we do about it
number one you need to force yourself
to shift
your attention to solving other problems
that are more mild so take up things
like
putting puzzles together okay or maybe
um playing chess with someone or some
type of craft where you're actually
working with something with your hands
and so you're kind of getting yourself
out of your head and your problems are
shifting to other things like a really
good activity would be something like
bird watching where you're just taking
your attention off all these problems
and you're focusing on something else
very very therapeutic all right next
step is to start hanging out with people
that support you there's two types of
people people that bring you up and
people that bring you down now even
within the youtube channels there's
always going to be haters and if you
have a youtube channel this can be very
very stressful and upsetting if you're
reading all these comments of people
hating you all that long but if your
adrenal glands are good and you can cope
with stress it doesn't it's not going to
bother you but with some people it's
very very devastating now with me i have
the ability to delete those people and
block those people which is very very
nice and they don't bother me anymore
because i have so many people that
support me which i that's you right
there watching and i really really
appreciate it so it's interesting the
different channels out there i mean like
what is the goal is it to help people to
provide information or is it just to i
don't know entertain people by
criticizing them i mean that doesn't
make sense to me but the point is that
you just need to start hanging out with
people that only support you and
don't hang out with anyone that doesn't
support you all right number three
vitamin b1 b1 b1 nutritional yeast has
the natural b vitamins well if you
haven't ever tried this vitamin b1 in
the form of nutritional yeast make sure
it's non fortified with synthetics okay
because they put they use petroleum it's
not a good
thing when they put that in nutritional
yeast whether it's in tablets or a
powder when you take nutritional yeast
within about three to four minutes
you're going to feel like
stress relief because stress depletes b1
and vitamin b1 will just take the stress
right out of your body and you'll feel
relaxed you'll feel less
internal tension it's dramatic
and it works like nearly 100 of the time
next thing that you want to do is start
eating more foods high in potassium
because potassium is lost with high
levels of stress you can also do a
potassium supplement but you want to
make sure that you have sufficient
potassium as well as sodium or or sea
salt all right regular exercise or
physical work
very very important
the more physical work you do the less
stress you're going to have you're
giving a lot of oxygen and you are
getting rid of stress
by physical activity
the worst thing to do is go through the
whole day get stressed out and go right
to bed i mean you haven't gotten rid of
the stress you have to actively
do something to get rid of stress
because all stress is accumulative our
bodies are a bucket of stress
all right number six
you need to do a detox from the news
the news is extremely stressful so you
don't want to watch the news for a long
time and guess what you're going to feel
much better all right last point is a
low-carb diet high carbs will make you
more stress
it's a fact that when you go on low
carbs
your mood is going to be elevated
so if you've had anxiety before you're
not going to have anxiety you're going
to feel better if you add intermittent
fasting as well so i have a lot of
videos on that topic now i have another
video that you need to watch
it's an actual technique that i walk you
through
how to do acupressure on different parts
of your body to extract accumulated
stress it's taken me a long time to
figure this out and i'm going to teach
you how to do it to yourself
and for some of these maneuvers you
might need someone else to do it on you
but it's very very awesome check it out
i put it right here
you